already starting off the morning my
favorite way which is
which is dancing
let's take this
music dude taco makes this stick his
face
oh really that's sick
my favorite way isn't jumping on curbs
it's eating at a diner and specifically
baby stacks yummy yummy
let's go duty it's a filipino breakfast
joint yep filipino hawaiian diner fusion
and as you can tell it's in the hawaii
uh filipino part of town next to
pampanga and they got all kinds of
actually which are open
filipino pastries
they are open 7 30 to 6 it's right there
you're filming it dude how come it looks
so closed i don't know because that's
their advertisement
let me see it sure
they are open all right
every time i come here i have to get
this i thought you were about to call me
out i was like you just told me to guess
i'm so sorry i traumatized you that you
feel that way i was like you just told
me to get it now best of adobo fried
rice they wrapped into an omelette and
just all those flavors are so good and
this is my first time trying their
cookie butter french toast i always get
the red velvet because that's um they're
like go-to right but
the ube yeah yeah can you take this out
for me i'm stuck in there but i have to
try it
[Music]
i should have got that ready before i
start vlogging
thank you i never eat sweet stuff first
but
i have to try it because i love cookie
butter
a little bit of cream
i think i've got a new
face wow that
was some fresh black coffee oh my god
wow
there you go thank you so much welcome
can i get some sriracha please sriracha
thank
shout outs to that hawaiian dude at
autozone you were so
helpful so ma bear wants me to inflate
her tires because her tire sensors have
been going off this is 36 or something
like that when i think it should be at
41.42
the max psi here says 50 so that sounds
accurate and in case you guys don't know
the amount of tire pressure that you
should have is always on at the tire i
do have an air compressor at home about
a beam by the boom you guys always see
me use it for our mountain bikes for um
tycho's tires and his toys and stuff but
i've always wanted to inflate tires at
home i just didn't have the proper tools
so i went in and i told them hey what do
i need to use my air compressor to
inflate the tires on my car
while still having a meter reading they
recommended this
and when i brought this to the front i'm
like cool that's all i need right he
goes well actually it depends on what
kind of hose connector you have because
depending on the hose connector this may
or may not work and i'm like oh well i'm
so glad i talked to you because if i
would have just bought it online i don't
i think i'll skip that part so
he told me there's two types there's
this type a1 right here
and then there's this type v1 it's
internal rt and since they're only three
bucks i ended up buying both of them to
save myself some time
and i'm glad i bought both
because seeing the connector that i have
at home it's this one
so the a is correct so i should be able
to plug this into here and then screw
this onto
this part right here
and i should be able to inflate tires at
home from now on which is cool
all right now that i finished filling up
the tires at mama bear's car
today's big task is
to organize the rest of the garage
remember last time i left off right here
and i feel like i did a pretty good job
of keeping it
somewhat organized
like there are like those straps that
shouldn't be out should be tucked away
that's kind of toppling over which means
i have rummage through there so i got to
fix that
this part i've been rummaging through i
need to fix that
but overall
it has stayed
pretty clean which i'm
proud of
but
this side
is
a mess things are toppled over
completely
random tools
a camera that's upside down
i gotta clean all this up and
my dad's coming over today which is cool
he's gonna come stay with us for a day
or two
while i show them
the house that i got um
from two vlogs ago so i'm really excited
about that and he's gonna be showing up
in a few hours so hopefully i have
enough time to i don't know about enough
time to clean everything because once
you get in the nitty gritty right like i
have all these drawers
like all these like little drawers
and you guys saw the movers from last
time they took my box of screws and just
dumped them so organizing each
individual screw i feel like it's going
to take forever but if overall i can
make it presentable then
i'll be very very happy so that's the
goal
all right laying everything back out
again if you guys watched the video
where i organized my garage for the
first time that's what i did and i'm
really happy that this time i have half
the amount of things
which means i did a good job but i do
have a bunch of random knickknacks
that's a rubber mat i bought for my
truck
but i don't need it anymore because i
have that deck system
pulling out all kinds of random stuff
like see these are the screws i was
talking about they just straight dumped
it like how am i gonna organize these
things so i'm just gonna have to toss it
the good thing is
they're not expensive i can get
i think each box of screws for like 20
bucks on amazon so that's what i'll
probably do but i do have a lot of
things to organize in here but this
looks good
so my goal is to
once i put everything in place make it
look like this but in here i have like
gun parts
you know like
slings holsters
first aid kits
see this is how the screws came i have
no idea why the moving people
would just open the box and dump the
whole thing i don't understand but
that's what they did
so if i can get everything all cleaned
up like this this will make me very very
happy
now that i have everything laid out now
it's time to organize
all right here's a little progress
report
doesn't look like much because this is
all the nitty gritty stuff i was telling
you guys about
but it took a lot of time and i'm
actually very proud of it and i just
hope i can maintain it
um so here it is okay i'm closing all
the drawers right now because i want it
to be a little surprise even though it's
absolutely nothing so
i've been able to clear out
this whole bench area
this is just some stragglers stuff that
i got to find like a home for
um but this is supposed to be out here
when i clean my guns or anything like
that if i need to keep about like you
know harsh chemicals that's what this is
for i like keeping all my
lanterns and lights here and i always
have one charging just for an emergency
that way i always know i can come in the
garage if like the lights get shut down
or the city grid gets shut down i have
boom light which equals visibility and
boom weapons which equals safety then at
least me and my family
won't you know are
in a safer situation for at least
like 12 hours to 24 hours and the next
thing i need to focus on is food in that
order right because already in shelter
so i like to have like what i call the
abc xyz in any situation where the plan
a plan b plan c
and then when [ __ ] hits the fan let's
plan x what's plan y what's plan z and
that's i always have that there
i have this here
now time to the organization
i have all my screws
like screwdrivers here
then i got
my hand tools here allen key all that
stuff
and then my
sockets
and stuff here
that's for the gym because it has a
big old lug nut and then power tools
here
with all the drill bits and since these
guys share the same battery i have an
easy access over here
then i got
air tools
which you guys just saw so i like to
pump a basketball
tire car
um as an air compressor to like dustings
off go shh like that
um i have my air tools there
then i have
screws or these aren't screws these are
like nuts and bolts
and screws i guess and these are the
screws that you drill into the wall
and then i have my gopro stuff here
and then that's like my dive housing
which is why it's red
to counter balance the blue
then i have
match grade ammo
match grade meaning it's for like
tournaments and it's extremely accurate
and no not every single bullet is made
the same they have different fire
capacity different velocity and so i use
a super expensive ammo those guys are
probably like three to five dollars a
bullet
when i'm zeroing my sight meaning i'm
like fine uh tuning and fine adjusting
my sight to make sure that it's right on
point and so i use a super expensive
ammo to do that and then i use the
cheapy ammo which is all the stuff down
here which i've also organized
um to do my fun shooting
down here gun cleaning kits
and then here
just random gun parts that i have
like trigger assemblies i've taken off
of my old weapons
empty drawer so far and then
all my other gun parts like mags
holsters that kind of stuff so
i've been working on this for like the
past hour or two feel like i made a
pretty good debt looks good to me
and i gotta just keep going
all right so it's night time as you can
see and i spent the last couple of hours
meeting with my pops and showing him the
house that we got him and it's really
cuny connecting with them because that
dude drove
four hours over here he doesn't even
have a cell phone
he wanted me to buy him one so i did buy
him one but i realized i can't just ship
it over to him he's not gonna use it
so we met up at the most asian place in
the world 99 ranch we said we're gonna
meet up at 3 p.m and if he shows up
earlier he's going to borrow someone's
phone and calls me and guess what that's
what he did i get this weird number but
since it's around three i was expecting
from my dad to call
so i'm gonna pick up every single number
that comes in usually if i don't
recognize the number i don't pick it up
pick it up lo and behold it's my dad go
to 99 ranch
in chinatown we meet up
and uh i was able to show them the house
and all that stuff
what happened to this one i have to go a
specific way
but it was cuny
because i got to see tyke and grandpa
play and hang out i'm gonna grab korean
barbecue and now i want to show you guys
what ma bear's been working on because
she's been on an organizing frenzy and i
have no idea why tycho won't let me go
through here
okay mama show me what you did because i
heard you were you've been progressing
and doing all kinds of stuff too
who you've been talking to
you told me in the car oh you then why'd
you say i hear you weirdo because i did
i technically did here i actually did a
lot on this floor and i was really
really happy with my progress i think i
didn't get to do as much as i would like
to i love to organize and i love to make
things as efficient and as thoughtless
as possible so i do a lot of work in the
beginning so that i can just live my
life without ever having to think again
so one of the things that i did that was
bothering me ever since we moved in here
and it's not even a big deal but it's a
big deal for me because it just [ __ ]
bothers me is reorganizing my shoes
um what'd you do so when we moved
they unorganized everything and it was
driving me
crazy i've been complaining about the
movers too because you know me and my
nuts and bolts situation oh i was like
oh
yes
yeah they [ __ ] it all up yeah i'm like
why do you have to open the box and toss
it i know it's like they purposely went
out of the way i can't blame them for
this because they didn't understand the
system yeah but i'm just saying like
ever since the moving happened
regardless of who the movers were ever
since the move happened
they just put everything in boxes and
they didn't think of anything which is
fine but it took me up until now which
we've been leaving here for what six
months seven months yeah to finally get
to it so what i did was i took
everything off the shelves i really
dusted everything everything out holy
[ __ ] yeah it's not that much it's just
four it's like one two three four five
six it seems like a lot of work eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fifty sixteen
seventeen oh [ __ ] that is a lot of work
so i took all the boxes off the shelf i
dusted them like i wiped them all down i
felt so good i felt like i took a shower
and then i started organizing them based
on like high heels right so i went high
heels what i would wear most likely
would wear to what i probably wouldn't
wear and the ones i wouldn't wear are on
top that's what those are my platforms i
see i'm 5 11 but i have to
have to have high heels um and then i
kind of just moved on that way ended up
at the boots right so we go high heels
to boots so can you see the thought
process it goes from open toe close to
yeah there's a logic behind it yeah i'm
[ __ ] a little bit psycho i get it no
you're just organizing is the way a man
would yeah so then i went to my boots
boots from high heels obviously color
uh height all of that all the way down
to my flat boots so i go from doc
martens and i and this is where i start
going based on brands so i go based on
brands and then i go be within that
brand which one would i wear
uh on a day-to-day basis and then the
ones that i would wear
on a day-to-day basis i keep on the
bottom tier the ones that i probably
wouldn't wear i keep on the top tier
because that's more of an inconvenience
to reach so here we have all my vans
batman van vans so these are the high
tops or the skates and then these are
the lows and then it transitions to the
next brand i only have one pair of pumas
this sounds ridiculous um converse and
then it transitions to my a6 so it goes
like this i have to stop the a secure i
can't have it here because i can't have
two rows of asics i sound like i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill people and start eating
their body i don't know what you're
talking about really it goes like this
vans to a6 and then it goes a6 that's
yeah why is it why is it s why isn't it
just this
oh because i i probably wouldn't wear
these oh so it has to go back up i can't
have it down here because then i have
two a6 and then now the new bounce has
started up here that's weird can i tell
you how i would have done it the ocd guy
yeah so the ocd guy
since these are asics yeah they would
have been in the a section that one is
a6 right yeah that would have started
here since i don't have any more asics
empty empty empty oh i can't have that
why because it's the waste of space i
just have to buy three more asics to
fill up the space nah i can't do that
see i have more of this baby you
absolutely 100 have low cd i don't yeah
so i did that the next pass is oh and
any shoes that i didn't want i'm just
giving them away um so i got rid of all
the shoes that i won't wear anymore the
next phase that i want to do that i
haven't done yet is just all this stuff
but let's go out that kind of took me a
minute
and while all of that was happening i
was doing loads and loads and loads of
laundry because we haven't done laundry
in two weeks and by we i mean i haven't
done it yes i'm usually a designated
person and i love my process so please
if you hate doing laundry because of the
folding this is what i do and it's been
a game changer so i put [ __ ] in the
washer right once it's done washing it
goes obviously into the dryer i put
another load in so i have two things
going on at once once this one's done
as it's in here i'm taking it out one by
one and folding it and i start folding
it and i put it in piles mama's pie
always goes here papa's paw always goes
here and then taka's pile always goes
here so as soon as it comes out of here
it's immediately getting folded so i
don't have to think about anymore i love
that i don't have to think about you
thinking about it so as soon as it's
getting folded this one goes in here and
i put my next load so things are
happening all the time once once the i
get this out and now i folded everything
these two are gone i go back and i do
what i'm doing right so did all that put
our clothes away except for papa's cause
papa's looks like i like that you're
describing
doing laundry as if you're a stock
broker things are happening all the time
i get a phone call come in they say buy
me two thousand shares i go you know
what i gotta sell the thousands here to
get the two thousand shares i actually
really do enjoy housework yeah i enjoy
organizing [ __ ] so i didn't really get
to organize papa bear stuff but this is
all the laundry i did and folded for him
i'm not putting it away from him because
he has his own way of putting [ __ ] away
yeah that i just don't want to take on
true i leave it here i'll let you handle
it as that was happening what if you put
it away and i follow your method
i don't want to think about a whole new
method
please god no i don't have the time fine
um didn't get to the bed yet uh but what
did i get to oh i did this area over
here was bothering the [ __ ] out of me
because i have a bunch of towels and a
bunch of bedding that i don't even use
so i it was like spilling all over i
wish i would have taken it before
because you did do a good job though you
guys would be totally proud of me but
um i threw out a lot of
uh uh towels and i have this tendency of
once i don't want the time like oh i'll
just make it a rag so then i move it to
another area where we can use rags but
it's a rack plate but we never use it so
now it was stuffed i'm like [ __ ] this
i'm just gonna like get rid of
everything all the bedding was all
mismatched don't have it anymore
organized it this is all i'm gonna keep
i went over here and i organized this
stuff
my monthlies all my little like
dresses wow nice like um
yeah
like why the [ __ ] do i have feathers in
this like
it's not even for wild times with bart
it's just because i'm a [ __ ] freak
show and i'd love to dress up
so i have it here uh what else thank you
i think i did all of that in a span of
like three hours good job thank you you
did a good job proud of you
you did you did the mama version of what
i did the stuff
and
we'll go to tyga's room
okay so for this last one i can't take
all the credit because my boy right here
dad's boy
he actually cleaned up his own mess
really
oh okay you show me you show me
[Music]
okay you go go show me time the lights i
can see
okay
okay
okay
wow
yes you did he cleaned everything up all
by himself
airplanes i i i put the app in a
straight line wow that's an airport you
made an airport yeah that's so cool he
actually wanted to make his bed but i
was like no dude you're just going to
get in it again yeah you just kind of
like tidied it a little bit tighten it a
little bit he's so cute when he's so
little he just slides in like a little
hot pocket so it's really neat well
what's even cuter is his whole length is
just here
so he has this big ass bed shout outs to
um lol bed for giving us forgiving type
at his bed he'll go into it um but yeah
he picked everything up he put all of
this stuff away
what a good organizing yeah so while he
was doing that i was able to replenish
all his diapers and i want to announce
to everybody
what did they say about this this
diapers these last diapers
because i'm a big one and that's why i
had to wear underwear yeah
that was awesome
so cute the room the living room under
our list of shoes yes
i was getting to that dude hold on so i
told him this was the last pull-ups he
normally he doesn't wear them throughout
the day we only wear them at nighttime
because there are accidents sometimes he
gets a little too cold sometimes he has
dreams about using the restroom and we
do have accidents he only has had maybe
like three accidents under three i think
yeah maybe even two
but i bought them already i'm like well
let's just use it
um so this is the last of his pull-ups
and he officially becomes
a big big boy wow
and watch this
you got it dude you got it dude
whoa okay so this is the cool part that
he was just telling you guys about was
as i was like frantically working on the
dryer while like doing my shoes while
doing the
the uh folding and then the towel thing
i was like oh man grandpa's coming and
the downstairs was such a wreck show
that i was like oh man i gotta go
downstairs and clean it and ted goes no
mama i'll go clean up my mess i'll show
you come here
so then i was like
oh
he organized everything
and then i put an input that the rainbow
slippers to the stage oh i forgot that
part yep tell him tell him i put i put
the slippers
next to the stack and then momma comes
out and they say wow
i did give you a big hug so um those
slippers down there are my house
slippers yeah and he strategically
placed them at the bottom of the stairs
he placed them so that as soon as i walk
down all my feet have to do is just slip
into them so he even turned them
so they were like yeah so it's not like
the shoes were like this you know what i
mean yeah it's not like they were like
this or like pointing like this and then
i have to walk around and put them he
literally put him this way so as soon as
i walk down the stairs i just go that's
so thoughtful monkey
yeah and this and then
give me as he was like walking
and i was like you're gonna get a big
old hug
that's cuny
you are the best helper ever dude and on
that that's how we cleaned our house
today and we will see you guys tomorrow
good night